we want to leave you with a little
something to take on the road something
we like to call ross
the doggy bag
[Music]
that's right that's right jeremy and
today
it's dial-up home an incredible poem
project built by the late poet
john giorno back in 1968.
john wanted to revolutionize how people
engage with poetry so he created this
hotline so that you could call
and hear a poet read their poem and now
you can actually access it
through the free dial-up home app in the
app store
you can hear poems in the archives of
people like patty smith
jane cortez and amiri baraka
the app also features brand new poems
from authors around the world too
but what's really cool is you can
actually call on a phone
to a phone number and like it dials in
it's like old school
it's totally old school and i love that
they've just like reimagined it with an
app
i'm absolutely doing this i would like
to put in the doggy bag
my recommendation a film on netflix
called my octopus teacher okay
and this is a documentary and it tells
the story of a man and an octopus who
meet off the coast of australia and
develop a
very profound relationship listen here's
the deal
i'm never eating octopus again i need to
find a documentary on the toxicity of
macaroni and cheese or i'm never gonna
stop eating that
so when i heard that this documentary
really shows that there is a connection
between them i mean do octopus do they
have that sort of capability to bond
with humans really
you will fall i believe so enamored
with the journey of these two beings and
what they give to each other it's poetic
it's introspective it's
life affirming and it just has
this sense of calm and yet
a lot of revelations i really loved it
so you're telling me the story
doesn't have legs to stand on it has
eight legs to stand on
i want you guys to check out everything
michelle
butoh so to watch yes welcome to butopia
yes on netflix critics choice award
winner and i tied with jerry seinfeld
it's just a slice of heaven also
netflix is the circle huge huge
phenomenon
oh my god it's so good it's bad you're
just gonna want to watch watch watch all
of them
okay circle emoji send and
to read michelle's book survival of the
thickest
yes do that plus-size essays in a
small-minded world you better get it
the world cannot get enough of you so we
did three in the doggy bag with your
stuff today that's the first time ever
but there was just too much good stuff
to celebrate
it's a new album by an artist i'm
totally digging right now
his name is tash neal and the album is
called
charge it to the game and he's performed
with oh people like lenny kravitz
billy idol the who slash
and kanye west to name a few i love what
you
uh suggest music this is great drew well
we
love this artist um and
his album also has two songs produced by
dan
our back of the black keys wow and um
it's just fantastic so
download it or stream tash nails charge
it to the game wherever you listen to
music
for someone looking for something real
juicy and a real paige turner it's a
brand new mystery called
the last thing he told me by laura dave
it follows a woman who forms an
unexpected relationship
with her teenage stepdaughter as she
tries to solve the mystery
of her new husband's sudden
disappearance it's so hot
it's a pick from reese witherspoon's
book club you see the sticker
it's right there reese's book club and
it's already being adapted into a
limited series
for apple tv plus starring the one and
only julia robert
uh oh oh i've heard of her yeah yeah so
that's why this book is super hot
it's a show i cannot recommend more
it's penn 15 on hulu
and these two women who
wrote created and starring the show maya
erskine
and anna konkel who play their middle
school selves and it is just
hilarious and heartwarming and shows the
vulnerability and the awkwardness and
the
awesomeness of what it's like to grow
up exactly and you think it's going to
be sort of a gimmick because they do
play them
like their young selves at this age but
right away it's so filled with heart and
soulful
exactly what it was like to be 15 years
old you remember and
i have a hard time when it's all adults
playing kids buying into it but they
cast all kids that are the right age
like
13 14 15 and they blend in so well you
just buy into the world and it's such
an incredible look at young women and
friendship
and just what it's really like i feel
like i'm in a time machine
a lot watching it like it's real it's
accurate and it's amazing
you